la mayoría de nosotros está
familiarizado con el signo igual esto
viene desde nuestros primeros días
trabajando con la aritmética en el que
se usan expresiones como uno más
es igual a 2 muchas personas piensan que
el signo igual significa dame la
respuesta esto es que uno más uno es el
problema igual es dame la respuesta y
uno más uno es igual a dos pero en
realidad el significado del signo igual
es distinto se refiere a comparar
cantidades que la cantidad que yo tengo
del lado izquierdo del signo igual es
igual a la cantidad que tengo del lado
derecho del signo igual es decir yo
podría simplemente haber escrito dos es
igual a uno más uno y estas dos
cantidades son iguales o también podría
haber escrito dos es igual a dos y este
enunciado es totalmente cierto las dos
cantidades son iguales
también podría escribir
uno más uno es igual a 11 esto también
es cierto otra sería uno más uno menos
uno es igual
a 32 ya que de este lado del lado
izquierdo
111 es igual a 1 y del lado derecho
- 2 es igual a 1 y estas cantidades son
iguales bien y ahora quiero presentar la
idea de qué pasa cuando queremos
comparar números que no son iguales o
sea este caso ya lo vimos el de la
igualdad pero qué pasa por ejemplo
cuando yo quiero comparar números a ver
digamos que tengo el 3 y tengo
estos números no son iguales una forma
de hacerlo explícito es decir que 3 no
es igual a 1 esta es una manera válida
pero qué pasa cuando quiero compararlos
es decir especificar cuál es más grande
que otro entonces a ver vamos a volver a
poner al 3
vamos a volver a poner al 1
y en este caso pues 3 es mayor que 1 y
tenemos un signo para denotar esto y es
el signo mayor que y así se muestra
este signo lo usamos para denotar que un
número es mayor que otro o sea tres es
mayor que 1 a ver déjenme escribir en
palabras sería mayor
y observemos en nuestro símbolo tenemos
de este lado un punto que podemos marcar
y del otro lado hay una parte abierta en
el símbolo siempre el número mayor
estará de lado donde el símbolo tiene
esta apertura una forma de recordar cómo
funciona y cómo escribir el signo mayor
que es está del lado del punto estará la
cantidad menor y del lado de la abertura
estará la cantidad mayor esto lo
podríamos ver como una especie de flecha
por lo que podemos decir cosas como
uno más uno más uno es mayor que él
y qué pasa cuando un número es menor que
otro por ejemplo qué pasa si tengo el 5
y el 19
bueno pues 5 es menor que 19 como en el
caso anterior podemos decir que 5 no es
igual a 19 05 es menor que 19 lo que yo
quisiera decir en palabras es que 5
es menor
y como lo hago con los signos que
estamos trabajando
bueno pues utilizó un signo con la misma
idea que tengo en el mayor que y en este
caso el lado pequeño el punto que está
aquí lo voy a poner del lado menor y
después voy a utilizar el mismo signo
en donde ahora la apertura apunta hacia
el número mayor
y entonces 5 es menor que 19 y me
servirá para hacer cosas como uno más
uno
es menor que uno más uno más uno